بالتطورات الميدانيه اذا فدى مراسل
الجزيره ان طيران الجيش السوداني قصف
معسكر لقوات الدعم السريع في منطقه الجريف
شرق بالخرطوم بحري ومن حيث الفريق قوه
الدعم السري للجيش بتنفيذ غاره جويه على
احياء سكنيه متفرقه في الخرطوم من بينها
حي الكلاكله وان الجيش استهدف المدنيين
كذلك في حي الدوحه بام درمان وادانت الدعم
الدعم السريع ما وصفته بالعمل الغاشم الذي
يستهدف الابرياء كما رد الجيش السوداني
على اتهامات الدعم السريع قائلا ان مجموعه
الدعم تتبعثر وسط الاحياء على نطاق واسع
بالخرطوم واجزاء محدوده من الخرطوم بحري
للاحتماء بالتجمعات السكنيه واتخاذ
المواطنين دروعا بشريه
في الخرطوم ايضا قال مراسل الجزيره ان
طائرات حربيه للجيش السوداني حلقت في سماء
مدينه الخرطوم بحري قال ان قوات الدعم
السريع تصدت بالمضادات الارضيه للطائرات
التي حاولت قصف نقاط تمركزها في مواقع
مواقع عديده بالخرطوم بحري كمنطقه كفوري
ووسط بحري وطريق المعونه وافاد مراسلنا ان
سلاح الجو يحاول ضرب مواقع قوات الدعم
السريع لاخراجها من وسط الاحياء كما حلقت
الطائره الحربيه في منطقه شرق النيل قربا
جسر المنشيه وتصدت لها المضاده الارضيه
التابعه للدعم السريع وفاد مراسل الجزيره
ايضا بان اطلاق اصوات اطلاق النار ما زالت
تسمع في محيط القصر الرئاسي بالعاصمه
معنى من جنوب الخرطوم مراسله الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي ومعنى ايضا في الاستوديو
الاستاذ ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب والمحلل
السياسيه السوداني ونبدا مع طاهر المرضي
من جنوب الخرطوم ورصد
للساعه الماضيه في الساعه الماضيه كنت
معنا
الطاهر المرضي وتتحدث عن تحدثت عن ان
الوضع هادئ
ولا توجد الشبكات مباشره بين الدعم السريع
وقوات الجيش
نعم كما هو الحال الان كذلك الوضع في هدوء
حدري يسيطر على الساحه بشكل عام في
الخرطوم غير ان هنالك بعض الاشتباكات كانت
في الخرطوم بحري
وكذلك هنالك قصف للطيران في بعض المواقع
في منطقه الخرطوم الجنوبي الكلكله وتحديدا
في شهر 15 كان هنالك قصف بالطيران لمواقع
لربما يرى الجيش السوداني لها لقوات الدعم
السريع ليست لدينا معلومات كافيه بهذا
الامر ولكن كان هنالك تدمير لعدد من
المنازل في تلك المناطق
وايضا كانت هناك اشتباكات في شرق النيل
ولكن اشتباكات المتقطعه
الطيران هو الذي يحلق على سماء الخرطوم هو
الابرز في مثل هذه او في هذا اليوم تحديدا
لكن بصفه من حيث الاشتباكات المباشره لا
توجد اشتباك لا يوجد اشتباك مباشر بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ولكن
الجيش السوداني يقول انه يتعامل على عمليه
تكتيكيه لاخراج قوات الدعم السريعه لمناطق
سكنيه او في شوارع قريبه للمناطق السكنيه
مما صعب عليه مهمه التعامل معهم خوفا من
وقوع ضحايا مدنيين في هذا الاطار هنالك
ازمه انسانيه لكن هذا الوضع خلف ازمه
ميزانيه كبيره باعتبار ان هذه الحرب
الثامن وان الاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه للغايه
ومعقده كذلك
المؤنثه بالنسبه لي او كانت تنفدع بالنسبه
للمواطنين في هذه المناطق القريبه المناطق
الاشتباك
والمناطق التي يعني توجد فيها المحاله
التجاريه ايضا مناطق هذه الدخول لها يعني
خطر جدا جدا وبالتالي اصبح وهي او الاسواق
مغلقه كذلك وبالتالي يصعب للمواطن انه
يجلب اغراضهم من تلك المناطق الا في
اسواقيه ولا يوجد فيها كل احتياجات
المواطنين التحرك المواطنين على الرغم من
هذا الحضور الحذر هناك تحركات طفيفه جدا
وخفيفه بالنسبه للمواطنين تخوفا من اي شيء
يمكن ان يؤدي الى
يمس حياته وهنالك ايضا لاحظنا خروج من
العاصمه ولكن بالنسبه اقل بكثير ربما هذه
المساله ارتبطت باقل فنادق عدد الناقلات
التي تقول التي تقل المواطنين الى خارج
الولايه الخرطوم بالاضافه الى شفه كبير او
يكاد في بعض المناطق منعدم تماما الوقود
واغلقت الطرمبات الوقود كذلك كما ان مصفاه
الجيل شمال التي تمت الخرطوم
يعني ليس
الناقلات الوقود الى داخل الخرطوم بسبب
الطرق المغلقه وكذلك الخطوره الاشتباكات
في المواقع العبور وفي هذه المناطق يبدو
ان الوضع بهذا الشكل سيزيد من التفاقم
الازمه هنالك تصاعدت نبره الدعوه لوقف
اطلاق النار تحدثنا مع بعض الجهات التي
كانت تتواصل مع رئيس مجلس السياده ونائبه
منا الاحزاب السياسيه التي كانت تعمل على
محاوله اقناعهم لوقت دائم لاطلاق النار
يقولون انهم يتواصلون معهم وان الامور ما
تزال في طور النقاش وليس هنالك جديد يذكر
او التزام يمكن
يقصع عنه ولكن هنالك اتصالات يعملون ان
تكلل بالنجاح ومناشرات المواطنين ايضا
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني والعلوم المتحده
ومنظمات الانسانيه ايضا تسير في ذات
الاتجاه باعتبار ان الاو في المستشفيات
خطر للغايه وان هنالك في الدواء ونقل
الادويه بمكان الى وكذلك هنالك صعوبه في
تحرك سيارات الاسعاف وانقاذ الجرحى في هذه
المناطق كمان المستشفيات التي خرجت من
الخدمه في وسط الخرطومه والمناطق القريبه
من الاشتباك حتى الان لم تعود الى الخدمه
ما يصعب مهمه هؤلاء
الكوادر الطبيه في هذا الامر نعم ابقى
معنا الطاهره الم